Hello and welcome everyone
to the ActInfLab
Guest stream number 7.1 - Double-O-Seven point One, actually.
Very nice number.
It's May 28th, 2021.
And we have some
very special guests on today
who I will let themselves
introduce themselves
and then we'll go into a presentation
followed by a discussion.
So any and all questions and comments
just put into the live chat
during the presentation
and I'll be compiling those
so that we can make sure to ask them.
So please, Miguel, go for it.
Okay then, I'm Miguel Aguilera. I'm working
as a post-doc for a year now
at the University of Sussex
in the UK.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, so basically
I'm a lecturer
at the University of Sussex
in both the Sussex Neurosciences Sussex
I groups are interested
in sensory motor control in general.
Cool.
So Michael, share your screen.
I'll resize
and then we'll have a presentation.
Take as long as you'd like.
Okay. Okay. Thanks a lot for the hand.
Yeah, for the invitation.
Really happy to present our work here.
It's been really kind of fast
because we just released the preprint
between this I go about it's good for
people to get a lot of discussion online.
So okay, let's see.
Okay. Can you see this key?
Yep. So resize it now.
So go for it.
Okay.
So, okay, so this is this work.
So this is super brain
that we have just published science
and you've got like Liora and, and
we wrote it
erotically and familiar to Alex and said
Alex understands Christopher Buckley
from all from Sussex Montaigne.
What's acceptable for us now also.
Um, so then so they work this to focus on
some of the recent publications
about the free energy principles.
I guess most people watching
know that the free inadmissible is
was conceived
originally as a unified brain theory
integrating experimental data
into this tool. Yet
describe the relationship between action,
perception and learning and so on.
And more recently, the theory has evolved
and tried to become more general,
stating
that any non-equilibrium dynamical system
under some special conditions
can be interpreted as performing
by using an inference.
And this will be
broader the theory of leaving system
or a way to describe
how certain
living systems gave using the tools from.
But this an inference and
okay so so this is standard
so in principle this
this kind of schema of a brain
is predicting
an environment
could be using different systems
like cell or different between being sun
and what I imagine anyone familiar with
with the primary principle
in this kind of pictures
are lots and lots until to
to the different one sun so that being
so I think it's maybe it would think to
to to try to visualize things
in a new ways
because this one's happier
probably than than so many things.
Okay.
So so the idea is
so we are interested in in exploring this
the the point that different assumptions
behind the principle because
and in theory the primary principle
applies to very diverse systems.
But in practice
there has been very few attempts
to explore it, to explore all the steps
of the theory in specific systems
on what we want to do here is just not
and we want to understand
if we interview principle
on its mathematical assumptions
in the simplest system
and the simplest non-equilibrium system
that we can find on
this is a linear dynamics
that will span later
on under an assumption of the assumptions
that the coping between
elements are weak.
And in this very special case,
we can compute all the relevant
variables analytical line.
And this will be a very
this is a very interesting case
for studying in depth
all the mathematical limits and
okay so the the work in pretending today
is related to the latest publications
around the ideas of the FIP
and the monograph approach
and argue for a particular physics
on the most recent more recent paper
by Thomas Larson Carl
about Michael blankets the information
geometry and source thermodynamics
and specifically
we want to focus on on two questions.
The first question is is
how general is the free energy principle
that is from all the systems that we can
imagine
can top two aspects of the legal systems.
How many of them conform
to the assumptions that
that the the principle requires?
And the second question is
how informative is the principle
about the behavior of our system.
So if if our system
if the first one closed so if I is, then
conforms
to all the requirements of the principle,
then how much
how much do we know about the system?
Right. How much
the principle is able to inform us
about the behavior of this organism,
okay, so, so on.
And lose this we find choices.
But I will explain later in detail.
One is that and some of the requirements
of the principle
and are make it challenging
to find systems in the class of systems.
We explore that that find that
that much the required assumptions.
And on the second issue we found
is that one important step
in connecting the behavior
of the system to the
to the gradient of the free energy
to the free and in principle
involves the coupling from the history
of interaction of a system.
And this creates problems in the
interpretation of a system
behaving as if minimized in a free.
And I will explain that.
So so before starting.
Yes, one quick
note on the on the notation we are using,
which is bit different
from from the papers
on the on some of the literature
we are describing external sense
or octave on internal as it would be C
which is composed by some other states
Y sensory states
as active states A states x
also differently
than in the in the papers.
Both symbols
represent a vector on lattices.
So on expectations instead,
which were bold in
some of the papers here are represented
by these and variables like
and why am is sensible on some things.
The theory uses conditional expectations
given a blanket state and in this case
then the blanket states.
The conditional state
is going to be a parenthesis.
So this is the mean of why
the domain of external states even b
I know so we can compute the
these are useful and we will look
in marginal flows are this F variables
that they would describe later.
Okay.
So, so first we try to summarize
the different conditions
and assumptions that one needs to derive
the free energy principle.
And I want to make a summary
which will be just refer later.
So first we the free energy
principle assumes that we have a system
that we can describe as a line,
given
the stochastic differential equation
and this is just coming
non and always therm this omega
which is just random
and uncorrelated the white noise
on some flow function
f that could be any potentially
nonlinear function that describes
this time derivative, this evolution,
this deterministic part of the evolution
of of a variable C and in principle the
omega single center and its curious
is the matrix gamma
and because all the noise is independent
between elements.
Okay, so the first condition
that the free energy promise of a rise
is that the flow function decouples
what the theoretical autonomous
and non autonomous states
meaning that internally states x
are not going to influence
external and sensory states
on external states are not going to
influence active internal states on this.
So this is what
and what we generally expect
from my sensorimotor loop in an agent.
And so if we have and we represent
this evolution of this system
like a nebula or integration,
so the external states do not influence
active,
internal and internal states
do not influence external sensor itself.
So we are going to require restrict
or analysis system system.
But this sensorimotor system,
the second condition of the principle is
that this system has a global attractor.
That is that the the probability
distributions of the state
of our system compared to some specific
probability distribution,
which is called P on this P
and it can be described by this reprise,
which is the negative logarithm
of this, of the probability,
which is how surprising
or how unlikely is a state.
And on this condition, we proposes that
and this global attractor
or this a steady state,
the distribution can be described
by the composition, are
helpful, holds the composition
or what on a or the composition
which
relates the flow function
with this or price by yeah.
To mitosis. Q and gum and gamma.
We saw it before.
It was just the covariance of the noise.
You is a matrix capturing
what's you call this
so I know that it flows in the system
on you some it's symmetric
on this solenoid outflow
so this is the mean mean that a
to the non-equilibrium influences
in the system.
If a system is at
thermodynamic equilibrium,
then Q is going to be zero
for all elements.
But if the system has an exchange
of matter or energy
or have some asymmetry in the interaction
between the parts
two is going going to be non-zero.
And okay, so we are going to have these
distribution terms, gamma
which are these this the of lines
then we are going to have gold links
between elements with this solenoid
all influences that are captured by these
blue arrows here
this one with the arrows.
Okay,
so that this is going to the condition
and the last condition that the friend
or even for who Christ is
the Marco blanket condition.
This may be very well known
which requires that
so that the sensorimotor states
based on they
and which are generally called
blanket state.
But we are going to be compressing
the two.
So the condition requires
that this variable
are going to play a very special role.
The coupling internal and states
in the following way.
And they are going to if we complete
our conditional distribution
picks and be on off
into extremely different states,
this is this is going to be independent
for our peaks to be.
So they are not independent in general,
but they are independent for a specific
one state.
Okay. So can yeah.
So these are those are condition
are statistical dependencies.
They are given B,
we have Y and X, but they are not
and they are not statistically correlated
for a given B, okay.
And so on in this sense
that this blanket states are going to be
like are a boundary or a barrier
between external and internal states.
Okay.
So, so these are the conditions required
by the free energy principle in real
meaning that we said these are
the prerequisites that we require.
So for a system to and to, to,
to display the properties
proposed by the three in, then
okay.
But outside of that a we interpret
and that the theory has some
three extra assumptions.
So these are not conditions,
these are not restricted by things that
the theory expects to happen or expect
to find that this in some some cases
on the for explaining this
it will still explain before
and how the theory proposed that
and variational pre introducing
both in the behavior of our system.
So so the free energy principle proposes
that any system under these conditions
that they describe
can be seen as minimizing or RC.
It's going to behave
as if minimizing operational free energy.
So for I'm for defining this free energy,
we start with this
price of the blanket states.
So the blanket state, this is what
an agent can observe in environment. They
do not cannot access the environment
directly because of the sensorimotor
structure that we have,
but only can access the blanket states,
the sensors on the actuators and
if our system is is
behaving as if minimizing the free energy
or and doing by using inference,
I should think with this one to behave
as if minimizing the
and yeah, this reprisal of this
this is that
and okay but
but the system cannot access
this probability,
the probability distribution directly,
but because it doesn't really
cannot access the environment
so and so that by this
an inference prescribes
to use a lower bound of this or price.
Okay,
which is called Operation Free Energy.
And this Operation Free Energy
consists on the short price term
plus some divergence
with some real divergence
between the actual probability
distribution of the environment.
Given the blanket on the model
to a simplified model of the environment
and on by.
But is an inference consists
in finding the parameters
out of this model
that minimize these this instance.
So in this
so when this distance is minimized,
then the agent runs
a model of the world and is predicting
the the
states of the environmental right.
Okay so so solving the
but you see an inference problem.
So the simplest way
the simplest way of doing
it is just doing a reading descent
minimize mutation of these free energy
which ends up in being not reading
descent of of the of
of the environment.
Why but at the most likely states
data on the blank.
Okay, so, so here I guess that yes.
Parameter
is the most likely state of what.
Okay.
So, so then the free entry
principle defines the most likely states
of the end of the system
on the environment.
Peaks in a blanket.
Yes. Like the the mode or the arc max.
But sometimes it has been proposed that
the mean it's a no fault for doing this.
And since we are going
to use the systems,
the both are going to be the same.
So you can interpret this as the mode
or as there
and as the mean of of Y and Z and B,
and then you can if you remember,
you will have the flow functions.
If you can compute
the average flow of the system
and why for a given B on
which we saw in this assumption
that can be described by these models
you on game
on the gradient on this price.
So if we want to find something
like the gradient of this or price
that we have here
and the fact that if we get this loop
proposes that we have to compute
the average of of the flow given B
and we obtain something like this
and we
can see here that the first term is the
what we want is the gradient is sorted
with the gradient of this price.
But we have to make certain
and so if we have
so we have some, some grading like these,
we could if we had something
like the first column in this equation,
we could interpret
and we can use this orient
to perform.
We could use this way to perform.
I mean, you may see some of these energy
would say interpret if we interpret it
and strictly
it could mean having somebody
that follows this gradient.
I'm sorry. 1/2.
Okay.
And okay, so so if we have okay.
So on the that this also yes,
that this part of the city is going to be
the most likely states of external
or internal states.
And again, this so so we have
so we have this equation here,
this solution 12
and we just need the first term.
So in general,
the free energy principle proposes that
the couplings
of this matrix to the non by the
and are going to be zero
and okay so so okay
so this is our so each element in
this is a block
I'm have many a number of dimensions
on the free energy
principle assumes that okay
well at one interpretation this could be
is that it assumes that a removing this
or you know they'll coupling this non
block diagonal groupings
then we are going to remove
these elements that we don't want
and we are going to have a flow of
this is then equal to this gradient
on this replace that is the gradient
that minimize the free energy.
Okay.
So, so this is the first assumption.
If this if this few terms
are equal to zero,
then we have an average flow
that goes in the direction
of minimizing the free energy.
And this is interesting because we will
have a system that points and
in either
the screen again what we
it was inadequate
in some works
it is proposed that there's
some general form of this matrix
that is not is also blocked diagonal
but not within Y and Aswany.
But we think they are autonomous
or none of them.
So what I mean is on an X
and this is the case,
but it's not a possibly
this is not a clear
how you can derive in this case.
And this gradient of the free energy
and what it's suggested that
the sorry noodle copies can run sellout.
But but yeah.
But so
who are we to consider the two cases?
But of course it is in principle, yes.
The case of complete.
So this first assumption
means that the cocoons between
elements are
or can be approximated as sirup.
Okay.
And the second assumption
and is therefore in.
Okay, so we have a flow of extra states
that's
pointing in the direction
of minimizing the free energy.
But we want to interpret internal states
as minimizing this free energy.
So what if a slope proposes
to solve this?
So the proposal is that there is a smooth
mapping sigma that connects
the most likely improvement states
with the most likely standard state.
So this and Y is equal to sigma x
and on the assumption
is that there's a gradient in both the
our of there's a gradient or distributive
anybody this mapping that exists.
So the mapping is differentiable
and that it is similar to what
we proposed.
The bias that we see on request requisite
for this assumption too
is that the mapping from B to an x
is injected.
Okay, so this mapping exists.
Then we can connect the external states
with the internal states
and we know that the external states
of uphill that point in the direction
of minimizing the penalty.
And so the hope is that now
internal states,
if this mapping exist, are going also
to have a flow that's pointing in the
direction of the free energy
and the loss of function.
And this is maybe a more controversial
is that if we work off
on strict interpretation of the
gradient descent on of opinion or D
and the the assumption will be
that the dynamics of the most likely
states are approximately equal
to the dynamic to the average flow
of the external states.
So, so this is the derivative
of their average two states
on the right side will be the average
of the relative to some sort.
So, so this is saying something like this
and approximately
the derivative of their rate
is going to be equivalent
to the average of the derivative
because it flows yesterday.
But the derivative of the, of the system.
So if this assumption will be true, then
not only the flow of external states
point in the direction
of the free entity, but also the dynamics
of the system of the
are minimizing the free energy.
And this is interesting
because if we had this if this is true,
then we have some equation like this.
So the derivative of y is equal to the
gradient respect to m y of this or price.
So the dynamics of y are being achieved
minimizing the free entity.
So we so this was in 20.
So we know that the dynamics,
the behavior of the system
is going to be minimizing actively
before gradient descent on the free
pre and on
if this is through and we have
the mapping that a assumption to propose,
then we can use the chain rule
to find that connection between
between the derivative of y
on the derivative of in white.
So the dynamics of the external states
on the dynamics of the internal states,
just with the gradient
of the sigma function.
So this is just a ten
rule of the, of derivatives.
And with
this a step, then we can describe
the dynamics of internal states,
of the dynamics of external states,
and use this gradient
mapping to read this equation.
23 that tells you that the dynamics
of the most likely internal states
is doing
the gradient descent on the free entity.
So this is the end of the of the
of the argument of the free energy.
So, so if this is true,
then the internal states
will be behaving as if minimizing
the free energy about external states.
On then the internal state will be
the behaving as if effectively performing
by and by an inference.
Okay.
And on with the write out
from some of the states
in in this publication in the
and the monograph of that particular
property, which
this is on the most recent paper based
almost about microblogging.
So for instance your mothers
and so on because they they are
and this it appears to us
that they were using the same symbol
for the derivative of external states
and the average flow
because so in some equation
the recycle is
so for the change room
they use this symbol and
and so so this is the way
we interpret this in the in this way.
However, also from commercials
and from the offers
it's proposed that the the
the free energy
principle is not exactly proposing
that they receive.
So I think that the result would be that
the system is not doing on a straight
Caribbean descent as this assumption
three that we label with this is thorough
because it's in part or interpretation.
But that the alternative
to these assumptions
that are three will be
assumptions are free,
which is that it is not.
And the derivative
of them of likely state
but follow the green of the energy
about that.
But yes, the flow, the average flow
so the average flow of it
Y is just the average
of the derivative of Y,
you repeat the conditional average with a
so this on
and the claim will be
that if the flow is pointing
so that if the average derivative
is pointing in the right direction
of the free energy,
then you can interpret
that the system is behaving
as if on average
it was performing a brilliant descent.
So so this assumption starts on three
would be that
not that the system is exactly doing that
gradient descent
on the free energy
but that it is doing on average.
Tonight we will have like
many observations of the system.
Then we will see that they on average
point do.
I mean,
it really starts with free energy,
but maybe not if we just observe
one system the beginning.
Okay, then
this assumption of three will be that.
Yeah, exactly.
You know, if,
if the condition average flows
follow the direction of gradient descent
on the free energy,
then the behavior can describe on average
as if minimizing the green.
Okay.
So this is
the summary of the different conditions
and assumptions of the principle in which
we will have competent interpretation.
At some points
like this assumption of three.
Okay, okay.
This is a lot of steps on on
it is hard to into intuitively
have an idea of what the goal is,
what yeah.
How we can expect from any of them.
So what we did is we tried to explore
these different conditions
and assumptions in our inability
to use this system to solve on
and on, see what we can expect
in this very simple case
and also our ideas.
The best way to really understand
this is to have a model.
The simplest we can have
and see how easy or hard
is for the different assumptions
to recall that we felt by this.
Is that okay.
So we substituted the large abundance
that we had
before by yes, a linear range abundance.
So everything is the same
and whether
we have a factor for the noise,
but this is one to read this one.
And we have we have
know the f function.
The flow is substituted
by a linear multiplication.
So we have a matrix
de which is saying Barcelona real,
which is multiplying
and the state of the system
minus some constant row
which is going to be the an offset
capturing the average state in
and in a steady state.
Okay.
And this system is going to be
our non-equilibrium system if
and the matrix j is is not symmetric.
Okay.
So in that case, we are
we have a non-equilibrium system
and we are going to have,
for example, spiral floors.
And so
the interesting thing
is that this system offers a steady state
if we let this is now run for some time
is when you have a steady state that's
going to be about in this direction.
Because if everything is linear on
the noise is linear, eventually
the system is going to wait
a steady state and thousands to watch it.
And in that
the limit of time can going to infinity,
the average of this Gaussian
is going to be yes, these are what
parameter on the cabana's
matrix of this multivariate Gaussian
is going to be this sigma star matrix.
And this Sigma
Star Matrix cannot be solved
analytically.
But is the solution of this equation?
29 is an equation
that involves the noise,
the coordinates of the noise, gamma
and the see
if in equilibrium
this model,
this equation can be solved analytically,
but we are interested in more generally
in non-equilibrium systems on these.
These equations are continuous
like the one off equation,
and in principle
it can be solved numerically,
which is not ideal for us
because we want to access
to the hub, the connections
between the parameters on the X,
but we cannot in general.
Okay, so what, what did we do?
And so in order to have a solution
of this equation, our general solution.
So we assumed the following.
We assumed that
the couplings of J can be defined
as some term I
and this is negative just to ensure
the stability of the system.
So if the Y, if I is positive and larger,
then you will have our debugging system
and then
we have a non that you're going to call
a C and we assume
that these C terms are small.
So if we have C, A square
or C to the power of three
and these are going to be
negligible terms.
And in that sense, we can see if we have
that we can solve this equation,
you know, in terms of up
over 36 functions so we can solve like R
so this would be equivalent to our Taylor
expansion that you can see in calculus
and we can have an expression of this
sigma,
the coordinate matrix of the solution
in terms of increasing followers of C so
then the linear of the quadratic terms
on some
terms that we are going to know. Okay.
And to make things more
easier, we are going to assume
that the noise is somewhat homogeneous.
So Sigma, is this a density matrix times?
Some constant. Some constant.
Okay. So
okay, so we choose value.
So and so if y
so the conditions one and two are
almost automatically true.
If y is now dependent on C
and we have a global attractor
and also we can define J
A to have
the sensorimotor structure that we want.
So we will need to condition three.
So condition
three is the mark blanket condition
and proposing that they blanket
the states or the central
and other states play a very special role
being a boundary
between external states and domestic,
so that the distributes
the condition of distribution
is an independent distribution
given the blanket way unexciting.
Okay.
So in our Gaussian distribution
and this condition is true,
if I leave the same matrix
which is the inverse of the covariance,
satisfies that the definition between Y
and X, the chasm between internal
and external states a little bit.
But this can be a matrix.
If the dimensions of Y and Z are
more than one, then it is equal to zero.
Okay, so we can very easily compute
and what's the form of discussion
with these approximations?
So we have the question
how common are Markov blankets?
Not for them.
All the systems in the world.
And how often can we expect
if we have. Yes.
Run the parameters to find the Markov
blanket.
Okay. Okay.
So we want this matrix H
which is the inverse of the covariance
of this steady state distribution
and that we can express this
inverse again I suppose serious
and this is called a new monster
is for completing the inverse optimizer
and so on.
It has this form.
We have again
a linear term on a quadratic term.
And so in terms of the way I to ignore,
okay,
so we just need to know, see to know how
what's it and to know this
corner of the matrix is equal to zero.
Okay, so, so C is going to be like this
because we impose these
specific sensorimotor other structures in
we to excellent on stage.
So an influence internal and internal
don't influence experiments on.
And so for the first order approximation
we have this equation 36
Okay.
So yeah, for some of that approximation
we use this term of the equation,
we going to see which is C plus
the transpose
and just switching rows and columns.
We can see that if we sum C plus
and transpose the term in the corner
is going to be equal to zero,
which is what?
What do we want?
So for our first order approximation,
we have an exact
mark of blanket on the mark of Lang
if this were always going to be true.
So this is what we wouldn't
use in principle.
And if we if we are,
what if we want more position,
we compute the second or third.
So we get this quadratic term here.
We find that the corner of the Hessian,
the one that has to be
zero, has this form.
So in principle,
this is not going to be zero
or is going to be C
or just for very special cases.
And if we look at the
connectivity structure of the
of the system, so that kind of system
with a loop that we require in general,
is this a canonical loop?
a3a So simple for this, a structure,
very few systems
are going to have an Oracle blanket
because this is
not going to be C or exactly
almost never.
And however,
there is some other configurations
that are going to have a mark of blanket.
If we have a it will have looked like
this is B or we have something like this,
a structure in C,
then the relevant then
then the terms appearing in this equation
are at least one of them is zero
in both cases
and this is going to be zero.
So we actually are going to have a markov
blanket in general, but not a
and there are second order approximation
on so under this canonical flow
constraints is a
only a few systems are going to display
and accept Markov blankets,
although but one exception
are going to be this circle of loops
or these symmetric loops on
however we, we, we felt
we we have to say that
the in the case of weak couplings
the macro blanket
this is still going to be a R
is in somewhat reasonable approximation
because if we have some equation
like this on a so so the first term
so even if we have something like this,
this is our second order, that equation
on all the other elements in the matrix,
I want to have
two components
that are going to be much larger.
So even if this even
if we do not have an exact or blanket,
this is going to be a very somewhat
reasonable approximation in most cases.
Okay.
So this is condition one one.
These are three. Sorry.
So let's go to the next
and the next one is assumption one,
which states that
they're so copious
between blocks of states have to be zero
in order to have a flow that points
in the direction of the free energy.
Or we could relax this assumption
on how these this get relaxed.
But those sort of worry
requiring some some students in here.
Okay and so we can drag right
the previous solution of the
of the steady state equation
to find a connection
between Q Gamma and J
and we would not it's sort
right in the previous question
we can read this equation quarter
and again this is
this equation cannot cannot be solved
directly in general
because each another on a continuous
reliable equation.
But assuming that we have j equal
Siemens Y like and the openness are small
as we have before.
We can do the same trick
for a new power series
that connects to with the values of C.
Okay.
And has this form which is similar
but a little bit different than the
case before
and so but this case looks a little bit
more complicated.
So first, we just completed
the first order expansion of
it looks like this
so so this is Q for our first order
and case ignoring this
the quadratic terms of C
okay again
we see that there is in principle
few cases where and then
yeah, where the assumption is exactly
because we are having
we want to make zero
all these things here
if we don't constrain the possible
parameters,
this is going to be true
only in very, very special cases.
We're going to see that the one way
to make so many elements of this
matrix
is assuming that they are symmetric.
You see, y is equal
to the transpose of these.
Let's see if the connections from sensor
to environment are equal
to the connections of environment
to sensor, then this is going to be zero.
And in that case we obtain this matrix
which has a little zeros by the still
there is these terms
that we cannot get rid of.
So if this code names are not zero,
then we don't have the assumption
the friend responsible.
And this is important
because this is all this is
this will be the the connection
from actuators to the environment,
which in principle is something
we will expect in many cases.
And this is the yeah.
And this is the connections
from sensor to internal states,
which is also something we expect in most
sensorimotor or we intuitively expect
from our cognitive system
with our sensorimotor loop.
And if we want to make these elements
of the matrix equal to zero,
then we need to have something like this.
Look, see
in which these elements are symmetric,
the JS and the non use are symmetric.
And also we removed the connections
from sensor to internal states
on actuators to external state,
which is intuitively
a bit strange about it.
But I think this is somewhat
the literature of the French.
And so what
this kind of look has been used
so unexpectedly
and because
proposed that this would represent,
for example, the the membrane of a cell
that separates the internal and
external states in this kind of symmetric
manner.
Although I think there is some well,
there is some research on cell membranes
indicating that asymmetries in them in
memory are still important.
So this is still a potential issue
for finding systems.
But that this
this cedo this look that you going to
and if we consider
the secondary approximations, things
become spookier
and we have many, many theorems
and we see that these elements
are just going to be zero
in very, very narrow set of cases,
which is potentially problematic for poor
and yeah.
For asserting that the principle is,
is to hold for it.
This assumption will be generated
for for many systems.
And this also gives you an that
we are saying this very specific case
with very weak opinions.
But I mean, this stronger
couplings in principle
will make things more complicated.
I'm not this here.
Okay.
So this is assumption one.
We only are going to get this general
and there are very specific circumstances
on this.
The only exception being this symmetric.
A look with this very,
very specific structure.
So so this is so in some connection
the Michael Blunkett exploration on them
on the exploration of this,
I will indicate that
in the class of systems
that we studied,
the free energy principle will be
will only emerge exactly
for our very narrow set of systems.
Okay, so,
so this is crystalline, so interesting
to think about how general
the principle lives or how can we expect
it to
be found
in, in, in different classes of systems
although we just restricted or
and I see students learning there once.
Okay so this second assumption
unconnected to the question
of how general
not not how general about how informative
this is in this assumption
is, is that there
we have this mapping between
internal and states
and if we compute
they're not likely interesting
going to states even a blanket.
If I go to any situation, we can do it
very easily to compete in our condition.
Elaborate.
And so these are the equations
of findings in textbook and multivariate.
Gaussians
And we find that if this requires
to compete
with the generalized birth of some matrix
and we find that
and we can in linear systems
and in some cases
if that the governments of
this model are correct,
then we can derive the mapping.
But this mapping,
if we have the correct them inside,
they think exist very broadly.
So this mapping is just going to be
linear matrix multiplication of
and the relation between and why am x
so so this is one this
and this might be an easy slide.
It can be expected to be very broad
if the dimensions of these variables
are correct.
Although maybe yeah, maybe it wasn't.
Not that in some of the literature the,
some of the verbal descriptions
say that this mapping
and it's a consequence
of the macro blanket,
but what we consider is
that they are in principle independent.
They they will emerge
even if there is not a markov blanket,
sort of at least in linear systems.
And so this
we and we discovered
that this result was also found
independently by by Lancelot Goldstein.
That work
that is going to be published soon.
And it's I think that they they got to
the exact same result as we did.
Okay.
So, so long to the last assumption,
which is maybe the most complicated.
And so the last step of the free energy
principle was to say that
we know that the flow of external state,
the average flow way, is pointing in the
direction of the free energy.
And this means
that the system is behaving
as if minimizing the free energy.
And I disagree that there is two possible
interpretations
for this and one for relaxed one.
So let's explore first
the strict gradient
descent interpretation,
which will mean that the derivative
of the average of the Eastern states
is equal to the average.
We can complete that very easily,
not linear system.
This this equation is the derivative
of the origin state.
This equation is just the average flow
on what we did for comparing
both is the US generating dummy
variable distiller m
which behaves
as equally as the average flow.
So this this variable to the end
will be a variable
that strictly minimizes
the free energy, right?
So, so we have
so this is the real dynamics of this,
of these state, of these
most likely states.
And this is what these most labile
states will do if they were exactly
minimizing the free energy
on there.
Or we could do an approximation.
We're going to see that we can get to
a simplified version of these equations
and we can see that
both of them are a bit different.
At first, the real dynamics has a know
noise theorem because the fluctuations
are going to affect the dynamics
because they're
the observations of the blanket
are driven by noise.
So this is going to be a noisy dynamics.
This is not on.
The second difference
is that this them changes this sign here.
So the here is positive
and here is negative.
And this seems to strange
but the reason of these is because
and these so this is the real dynamics
which depends on the previous state
on this and average flow
a its history independent in some sense
it just depends on the previous estate of
B, but it doesn't depend on the
previous state of why, so to speak.
So assume.
But since the structure of the of the low
of these variable, the dynamics of this
variable is going to be different.
And in this case,
this difference is captured
by this constant that has the difference
between one on the on the other
on if we're
on a simulation
of both of of both equations,
we find that the behavior
is is very different.
And so this is the behavior
of the real average variables.
So this is a system with two dimensions.
And you have these symmetric forms
because the, the
we restricted the couplings to plus -0.1.
And if we represent this builder and so,
so this is the system
that strictly minimizes the free energy.
We have this very,
very different behavior
which has this kind of weird
random walk on.
And this is because this
this variable is integrating
the fluctuations of the other one.
And so so there keeps accumulating
on the behavior is very different.
So in principle, it's unlikely
that the and these results were similar
for many combinations of parameters,
but in principle it's unlikely
that the dynamics of the
most likely states are going to be
so the
average flow is going to be informative
about the actual dynamics of the
most like you states.
Okay, so this is the sixth version
of the assumption that a relaxed version
would be that only the average flow
follows the gradient of the free energy.
And if we if
we interpret this,
we find that there is two problems,
or at least we feel that
that there are two problems.
And the first problem is that a key
step of the free energy principle uses
their synchronization manifold.
So the sigma function connected,
external and states
and then the rights are taking root,
connecting the dynamics of NY
with the dynamics of internal states
and this leads
to saying
that the flow of the internal states
is following
the gradient of the free energy.
Okay.
And so if we say that to the pre energy
does not really apply to the time
derivatives of the most likely states,
but this applies to the flow.
And then we cannot use the sigma mapping
to derive this equivalence between
what the external states are doing
and what the internal states are doing.
And so we cannot.
So this step becomes problematic.
And if we want to connect the flows
of internal states
on the flows of external states
as the US, the principal proposes,
then one would need a new mapping
because this mapping
and this mapping are not the same.
We computed in our system.
The two mappings that we find out there,
the mapping has a different expression
on it is different from the mapping.
That's the gradient of the mapping
that's using the literature.
So so in principle,
this relaxed interpretation will require
a different mapping that's different
than Sigma, because we are
not interested
on the flows of the most likely states.
But yes, on this average flows
and and on.
Okay, so on
what I'm more importantly
and another problem arises,
which is and yeah, certain
so so if we have an on this strict
the sort of 1/2.
Yeah.
If we following a strict
interpretation of the
sorry and what this.
Yeah.
If we're following the strict
interpretation like this like okay
internal states are following
a gradient, are doing a gradient descent
on the, on the free energy
so that they re but
the temporal derivative
is equal to the gradient of the.
So this is,
this is a definition of our textbook
gradient descent.
Okay.
And this is fine
if we have this equation, we know that
the system is doing a gradient descent.
So the question is,
if we just have this equation here,
so the average flow is pointing
in the direction of the gradient.
Can we really interpret
that the system is behaving
as if minimizing the free energy?
So how informative is this
average flow about the real behavior?
So we try to explore this.
So first and so
first in these simulations, we see that
it's maybe little improvement there.
Yeah, it would be little informative
even if we have a different mapping
and maybe this average flow
has little information about what
the actual dynamics is going on
for exploring this further.
And you can see it in the appendix.
So for
or for a preprint like this
and the second appendix
we tried to to explore
what is the connection between
the average flow and the actual dynamics
of the system in our very simple system.
So we restricted our system
to a bi dimensional case
with these and non-equilibrium behavior
or this is
so the flows of
this is not from this spiral behavior.
We under noise
are going to be rotating in this.
This is so
we have two variables, Y and B.
So this is
the flow, the actual flow of the system.
We ask, okay, so this thing,
what is the
the dynamics of the most likely states?
So this derivative of M, Y and even V,
and we find that
we have this negative slope, which is
where you have this distinction here,
because this is a random variable,
which is noise
and it's going to be noisy and so on.
But on our we have this negative slope,
meaning that the system is going to be
minimizing, is going to have an attractor
at zero, right?
If you study dynamical system,
some have a negative slope
of a derivative or at least our rates
you are going to minimize.
So if this state is negative,
you're going to reduce it,
you are going to increase it. Sorry.
And if the state is positive,
you are going to reduce it.
So you are going to have an attractor a0
which is what we see
in the actual system, but
for at
least for some combinations of parameters
which were like half of the possible
combinations of parameters that we tried.
If you compute the average flow, it gives
you the opposite effect behavior here.
This log is positive, meaning that
you have a system that follows.
This slope is going to diverge
to plus infinity or minus infinity.
So this is intended
as an example that the average flow
can be a very poor description
of the actual behavior of our system.
If what you have is are stochastic
dynamical system and.
Okay, so, so in general,
we cannot assume that
under all circumstances they might, you
know, flow is going to be informative
as the behavior of our system.
And even if you can derive
for all the steps of the free energy,
basically it may be the case
that in some systems the average flow
that this thing is pointing
in the direction of the free energy.
But the system is not behaving
as minimizing the free.
And, you know, you can see it
in this example and the system is
minimizing the value of Y Square
is going to zero, not the behavior.
The value of one of these variables
is going to zero,
but the average flow points
in the opposite direction.
It does do that if there is flow,
if you interpret the average flow
as what the system is doing,
then you will believe that the system is
maximizing the square value
of Y, for example,
because it's diverging on
what it's doing is just minimizing it
because it's going to zero.
Okay.
And so in principle, if the
if the dynamics
of the most likely states on the on
the average flow are different,
then yeah.
So they, they,
they are going to be in general different
in that case,
they are not going to be informative.
What about the behavior of our system
except in very,
maybe very specific basis?
I mean, feel approximations
of this kind of thing.
And and this difference
is because the these
marginal flows arise from the decoupling
of a previous history of the system.
And we are not considering the effect
of the effects of preparations
of operations.
Okay.
So just to finish on,
maybe let's give place to the discussion
and we in this work,
we explore the conditions to
on the assumptions
that are needed to derive the free energy
principle in linear or non-equilibrium,
stochastic systems and
some of this has
been explored for specific examples.
This work by Martin Bieler and others,
but I think it's interesting that we did
this for a general class of systems.
So it's not one example
that we solve numerically,
but we solve
a family of weekly persistence
and we see how general or not
are the different assumptions
or software software explore that we saw
how general are
the conditions and assumptions
of the principle and then we studied.
Under what conditions can we expect
and the principle to be informative
for the behavior of our system?
And we found that
the Michael Blanket condition emerged
at least as a good approximations
in the case of weak couplings.
But if the problems are not super weak,
are not very weak,
then we maybe we cannot expect
to be exact in our and however so removal
couplings are generally present
in all blocks of the system, so, so on.
They are going to be sealed.
Yes. In very,
very specific basis of this metric loop.
So maybe aberration two of the
for the theory will be to Yeah.
To explain
exactly what happens when these are not
sit on of what's what happens in the
so in
conclusion we would say that only very
specific structures are going to satisfy
their requirements to the right thing and
the to the right that the average flow
is pointing in the direction of the pre.
And the second point
about how informative the principle is,
we saw that the connection
between the free energy
and the marginal flow of the system
with the behave,
the actual behavior of our system is
is in most cases
very, very weak or even contradictory
as one can point in one direction
on the other end in the other.
So we found that this in general
that this marginal flows
are not capturing the actual
than only the system.
And this is because this marginal flow
ignoring the history of interactions
and we could intuitively think about this
so we can
have so we can imagine a system
that has many trajectories.
And if we fix the blanket at some point,
it just means
having different trajectories that
they are going to pass through this point
and the average flow
is going to complete the directions
or the direction of the
most likely derivative at that point.
Well, then the average derivative
of this system at that point.
But on any individual system
it'll have a very different behavior
which is represented by block length here
and so on.
And with this example for
this could be the end
to distinguish between the population
of an individual organism
and then of the organism and the rules
and their behavior,
behavior of a population.
So you can think that on average
a population of organisms
is, is behaving in a way
that and maximizing
the evolutionary fitness.
But this can be largely uninformative
for describing the behavior
of individual organisms, not that some
sometimes of the kind of criticisms
that we hear and to some proposals
in evolution, evolutionary psychology
and this kind of thing.
Right.
So, so even if at an average macro level,
you can detect some tendencies,
in many cases, these tendencies
can be uninformative about,
what an individual is doing.
Right.
And so so we think that it's interesting
to think about
and if and when and in which cases
the the and the conclusion
the conclusions derived by the
of principle are going to be informative
about the behavior of an individual or
or groups of individuals and so on.
Still, we have to say that and even if
we did this, what kind of political
evaluation we are still in,
we find that the day to day
motivation of the free energy
principle is is very
is very suggestive on.
And we think that the the aim
of connecting ideas from participating
for us with the dynamics of complex
arising system is tremendously important
as it will allow to apply the machinery
of what you see on an information
theory to describe systems
that are intractable in practice.
But but we also think that it's somehow
difficult to yes.
The right in a theory
and without connections
to the specific models right
that can allow you to
to inspect in more detail
some assumptions or some consequences
of the assumptions
that are difficult to grasp intuitively.
In many cases. Right. And
so so we find that the Yeah.
That it would be interesting to Yeah.
That exemplifying the steps of the theory
in a specific model
is very useful to to Yeah.
To is very useful to understand
the connections between the steps on,
the how likely or not are different steps
and that this,
this kind of exercise
can be really useful tool and yeah.
To talk to the
yeah it can be really useful to
to then understand the kind of
the difficulties that we face
when having a theory and just learning.
So this is the preparation
that we published,
particularly the physics of the energy
things.
So let's.
Thank you.
Thanks for this awesome presentation.
There was a lot there
and it was incredibly well presented.
So for those who are watching life,
I would invite them
to write questions in the chat.
But first, Chris,
I'll just pass it to you
for in initial comments if you would like
unmute and then please continue
by Chris your minute and then continue.
Yeah.
So Miguel, they we even though we
we finally put
a particular
kind of technical presentation, we see
we still find that
the kind of the ambition of the
British press was laudable. Right.
And we really something
we really want to embrace or yet
we feel that it needs some future
development.
Right.
So I mean, I summarized those two issues
that go as presented in the first one
is the problem
about trying to characterize
the interaction of an agent
with this environment?
So you can do this in two ways.
And one cynical way
to draw kind of connections and direct
functional connections between an agent
and the environment, right?
So the sensors in the motors and so.
On. Look,
there is a different way of understanding
those interactions in terms
of the testing or the covariance matrix,
which kind of great correlation system
rather than direct connections.
And I think what Carl is doing
is kind of really work
from the hat in awkward
rather than considering
the connections that underlie underlie
those to underlie those.
Right.
So he wants to assume there is a
mark up on it and wants to stop that.
And then he's not so concerned
about trying work out the cost of systems
that meets those conditions. And
I think that's a probably thing to do.
Might be a very special set of systems.
I think Kyle claims
that this kind of systems I'm interested
in, I'm not really interested
in the those of assistance. Right.
And what we've pointed out
is that we can't find those
very generally in the cost assistance.
And the second major issue
that I think Miguel's work points out
is this decoupling between description
of the deterministic dynamics
of the system versus
the average of an ensemble of systems.
Right?
So in there, in prior
accounts, the free energy principle,
you actually write the deterministic
dynamics into your description.
So when you're using for energy principle
to do composite systems,
you are describing the extent
deterministic dynamics
directly
in terms of your expectations and
and flows on your expectations
or what the particular physics
approach wants to do
is try trying to find out the terms
that omics within the physics, right.
It wants to see where it looks,
where it would like within
the kind of general stochastic
dynamical system series of physics.
And that's where the problems lie, right?
So it's very hard to go from the physics
to description in terms
a good description
of the system, in terms
of the kind of dynamics on expectations.
And so in that system,
so we can find this problem
of a decoupling between description
in the dynamics of the
the moments of assistant versus
the average over an ensemble of systems.
This is where the problem lies, right.
So there are over
an ensemble systems of free energy
might be a good description,
but it's not connected
to the causal explanation
of the dynamics of the specific system.
So you attribute
kind of to the right kind of mechanistic
description to that particular system
that you would like to.
And so that's kind of my summary of.
Thank you for the succinct summary.
That's very helpful for many, I'm sure.
Very if you'd like to unmute sorry,
I heard a feedback
when Chris was speaking.
So if you can unmute or.
Yep, okay.
Yeah. Ourself
and then give any comments you'd like
and then I'll go to the questions.
Yes, sir. Hi, I'm Ben.
I'm obviously an author on this and I'm
currently now a postdoc in Oxford,
but I work very closely with Chris
and Miguel at Sussex for a long time.
So yeah, all of the time
that I have some scheduling conflicts,
I jumped in for the questions.
But yes, so I would just like,
I think an excellent job of explaining
the issue with the average dynamics
of dynamic to the average.
But I would just like to go in
and kind of try to meet.
The important thing about the Michael
Blankets is really this idea
that the mock there is a huge distinction
between the statistical independence
relationships and this kind of like
causal actual relationship
you get if you have the dynamics.
And so it's quite easy
to confuse these two. Indeed.
I think we
we naturally conflate these two alike
until we start writing this paper.
And a lot of
the literature also like conflate these
and they have these intuitive diagrams
of like the bacteria with its cell
wall and everything
and that's the blanket and so forth.
But that's in this
because the level of the description
like in the things
cause we have to talk to the black,
but that's not the same at all
as the statistical description,
which is, you know,
the statistical interdependencies
between the blanket and the internal
and the external states.
And I think it needs quite
a lot of thinking about to what extent
these causal mappings
actually hold up and sort of
actually so sustained by the statistical
mappings or vice versa.
We found that linear systems
with lots of cases
where they don't
and they don't seem to match at all.
And so yeah, it takes
a lot of kind of intuition to really,
I think need to be built about what
these Michael blankets mean on an actual
causal level.
Thanks for this comment.
And again, people can right questions.
If I could just actually add something
about the difference
between the causal structure
and the correlative structure.
You can imagine on a market,
there's companies that are closely
related to each other, but
their stock prices are not correlated.
And similarly in the cell,
we often make networks that are based
upon like gene co expression, so genes
with correlated expression
and then there's gene regulatory networks
or protein protein interaction networks
that are like proteins that touch.
But those proteins
usually don't have correlated
expression because you might upregulate
one that then represses another.
So they're not expressed
in a correlated fashion,
but they have causal relationships.
So, so and it's people slipping
between oh,
gene regulatory network,
you know, co expression interactions,
certainly conflating the causal structure
of a system with the physical structure
or the correlative structure
is a broad category error.
And I think your work does an incredible
job highlighting the difference
and we're slipping between these easily
confused modes of thinking about networks
and then also conflating that with
reality or all of reality,
just very well done to.
These points.
Yeah, thanks.
I know that example would be like
the difference between structural
connectivity, functional connectivity
and effective connectivity
in the brain
that you can have some structure about
and then you can have
a statistical correlations.
But even then
the dynamics can behave differently
because these you have like these
asymmetries in
how one variable is connected
to another on on the opposite end
and this is also in the work,
the relation with the solenoid flows
that a couple of something
different then.
So yeah.
So it's
not very complicated to disentangle
all the all these different levels one.
But two to just do justice to the office.
I mean,
I think they're aware of this difference.
Obviously, Carlos
Creek is very aware of this difference,
but they feel that the theory sits above
the correlated structures and they're not
considering those causal structures.
I think maybe some confusion
might emerge in previous papers,
but in recent papers I think it's
very clear that he wants to sit above
the causal reactions
pool.
So I hope that by bringing the math
to examples
of like the market evolution
and fMRI, we can hopefully have
a lot of people giving their perspective.
So I'm going to just go
with the question from the chair
and then I have some questions
that I wrote down.
So first question, thanks a lot.
I was wondering whether you would assume
that going to nonlinear systems,
the limitations that you find
be even stronger?
Or would there maybe be an argument
that there could be nonlinear systems
that fulfill these assumptions?
So what will relaxing the linear
assumption do for the math
that you describe today?
Okay.
But that's a
that's a difficult to to answer question.
Yeah, I think so.
So so first is I think is is difficult
to well, it's difficult to solve because
in nonlinear systems in
general, we cannot find the kind
analytical solutions that we have.
Right.
And even in the case of linear systems,
we found that we can only solve
the case of weak objects
and in the case of weak openings.
And we will do the trick
of considering
different orders of expansions.
And we saw that,
including stronger couplings,
make things more difficult
rather than rather than easier.
Okay.
And intuitively,
I think my intuition
about nonlinear systems
is that the case may be
it may may be similar many systems.
Right.
That having strong yet
having more intricate couplings
more intricate dynamical coupling
school odd
extra terms
to some of the mattresses
that we are expecting to see zero
like in the blankets
but this is not something
we're going to see because of
or you will have unexpected effects
from chaos, for example.
I think that's something that
for a purpose is sometimes.
But I don't know.
I think maybe one interesting
direction of research will be
doing a similar expansion
to the one that we did
to say, okay, we have an almost
linear system, but we can see
there are very small effects of non
linearity and see what kind of currents
these knots to the to the matters
is that we are.
So this this will involve
a very different analytical solution.
But I think there is some up
for coming work
and from a yeah from some people
can kind of sloping in that sense.
So I think it's an open questions but
but I do think that in many cases
this is going to be challenging to
to to compare yet to see that linearity
is going to be assumption.
I mean you feel the intuition
is that you might be able to
solve in specific systems
what you used to.
The idea that you'll solve it
in a classic nonlinear system
seems seems doubtful. Right.
But you might be able to follow examples
that we see
augment with nonlinear actions
that meet the criteria.
Maybe if you constrained yourself
to a particular
evolved living system,
that might be okay, right?
But if you want to say more general
about the emerging self-organization
in a classroom is inconsistent
and perhaps run into trouble.
Due to when will go ahead very first.
That I think yeah I agree with Kristen
but obviously with nonlinear system
see how much bigger space of systems
and so you can probably find edge cases
where all the conditions not perfectly
but I mean the general intuition
these dynamical systems
the is the nonlinear systems
are a lot harder to deal with in general.
And so I'm not going to probably
if it's not satisfied in any systems,
there's no obvious reason
why it should be satisfied
in nonlinear systems and especially issue
with the dynamics of the average versus
the average of the dynamics
like the case we did, we have a linear
Gaussian system is probably the ideal
possible case for this because obviously
the average the linear operator in the
in the Gaussian case, the mode in
the actual average is the same.
And so you have
all these nice properties, none of which
will hold in the nominee general case.
And so I think in that nonlinear system
almost certainly can much much worse
so that specific issue.
Yeah those talk to and that I think so
so maybe so one question is
is whether there is linear systems
in which some of the problems
are going to go away.
But maybe the
the right question is what happens in
the kind of nonlinear systems
that that we expect in a living system.
Right on on what we know
from living systems that often involves
a bifurcation and so are critical points
that in that lead to a long range
correlations on correlations slots
that propagates through the whole system
and and this kind of that
can be very difficult.
So so the kind of isolation between
internal and strong states can be,
I think, can be challenging in
when this is the case right.
Thanks for all these excellent points
in complexity.
We often talk about nonlinear
as being like non animals.
It's like all of them.
So it's even harder
certainly to make a general stance.
And Bear now was a really interesting
point that as the state space
what's possible increases,
there may be more and more edge cases.
And that kind of brings it back
to the question about evolved systems.
Not every parameter combination of cells
is going to be functional,
and so maybe we're only dealing with
that vanishingly small amount
or some other.
I'm not going to, you know,
go to technical details on the fly,
but that could be one aspect.
And also it was such an interesting point
during the discussion when you explicitly
brought it back to evolution,
like fitness is the law of the land
in a way
at a level that doesn't explain
motor behavior in the moment to moment
there nested timescales.
And so, of course, there's motor behavior
that's maladaptive and long run.
You wouldn't see that under a stationary
ecology and da da da da da da da.
You start adding some assumptions in
and it's just,
I think, a very fruitful mapping
that will be explored
for time to come with the relationship
between population, population
level claims under stationary
environments, population
level claims under dynamical environments
at an individual level, claims under
stationary and unchanging environments.
So it's just a lot of topics
that come into play and
to have them integrate these kinds of
points that you're raising,
which are often implicit errors
in other areas,
they're being drawn together
and brought to the forefront
in a way that is quite novel.
Okay.
Again, since the technical details,
I believe, stand best in the presentation
as you provided as well as in the paper,
we can take any,
but I think that will be the place
where the discussion continues.
I just kind of want to ask a few other
questions to provide a little context.
So for maybe whoever wants to answer,
how did you come to be studying
the question this way?
Were you working with
the FP and exploring new kinds of math,
or did have more of an experience
with the mathematics and then see the FP
coming up onto the radar?
Like, how did each of you
come to be working on it this way.
Okay.
I'll go because I think I
can follow.
So, I mean,
I wrote a review of a few years ago
now of the original principle
at that time it was,
but it was quite
an enigmatic principle and understood it.
I mean, the reason
I originally I didn't like it.
I didn't like the of the notion
of representation, thinking pregnant
and the idea of the screening principle
kind of representing generative models.
But I actually came to like it
as a cognitive framework and I still do
like is as a cognitive framework
and I still still think within the regime
of describing sensory motor loops,
abstract sensing and cognitive systems,
it's very, very useful.
But then obviously there has been
a rapid development of this principle
into, into into a grander claim.
I find this principle in the physics
and in the course of physical systems,
and that's where I started
working with the young girls,
got a real strong background
in statistical physics.
And that's basically
what's led us to this, to kind of
really go back
to some of those assumptions.
So I do separate the two things.
I think there's still a very fine,
the cognitive account very feeling,
even though we find these problems
in these physics
examples.
Yeah. Yeah. I make this all then.
Well yeah for some I think when
I started to be involved
with the principle more recently I yeah.
For some things that is something
that I had on the radar but,
but actually understand it
what it meant like it's always seemed
it seemed kind of scary
until I didn't did the equations on
and I guess that's part of the motivation
for doing this work is
it was to as a way of understanding what
what the theory consisted of
because then you could go
through the mathematical descriptions
and it's often really hard to know
what the what they imply
or what they mean
exactly in the in the sense
that they are complicated math.
Right.
And I guess that they're there
during my research career,
the way I thought,
how I had four or understanding
complicated masses
by building models on this understanding
by building philosophy that's how you
so so I think that the initial attempts
to to build this system
it was an attempt
to really understand okay
this is step I can grasp mathematical
more or less what it means.
But, but
let's have a model since parameter
there's something with the and so right
so so that's the lesson or lesson
the journey that I'm on the once
having that having the model then say,
okay, I'll make up something more general
than just some specific parameters.
So try to see how we're going to have
an ideological solution and so on.
So, so yeah.
So I think, yeah,
this exercise is very fruitful,
both on a personal level
and also in a scientific level.
Because you've been on your way
to learning, you can develop things
that can be useful for the very boring,
you know.
Awesome thing.
All of those answers are very transparent
and also and also just if you like.
Now, that's why, you know, Miguel.
So just mute while Walburn
gives a different book driver.
To action to follow up on the point
really about just the importance
of actually trying to build models,
because I think my perspective
a lot of the of developments and problems
we discovered basically came from
actually looking at specific models
and then thinking, hey, this, this
doesn't quite work as it says it should,
because basically things
just become an awful lot more clearer
if you actually try
and build them, rather than just staring
at these sort of symbols on the page.
And so I think that's really the key
to it, to a lot of it
is simply trying to construct a system
where it's working and say, hey,
it's things aren't getting quite
as you know,
the particular physics
monograph says they should be.
Cool.
And it's so interesting
and maybe even appropriate that action
became relevance
for this inference problem.
So it's not just conceptual
because we must be engaging
in literature and conversation
in the work and going through it
ourselves in order to infer deeper.
We can't just wait at square one
and look all the way to square 1000.
We have to be working along the way
individually and maybe as a group too.
So here's a question from the chat.
Brilliant talk.
I wonder if Carl and others will respond
to challenges presented in this paper.
Also, because the paper is written
in such coherent style.
Wonder What would you recommend
for beginners to study in the AVP?
Nice question.
What do you wish you knew at the outset?
Even if it's a new resource,
what courses or topics
would you recommend having a familiarity
with or what are the on ramps for
somebody who's not in this area
of research and practice
how can they best
be on wrapping themselves?
So I recommend Baron's hope
he's got a nice repository of papers
which go from very introductory papers
to very solid state papers in nicely
organized ways to provide their own.
Is it public at publicly accessible?
But we've.
Publicly accessible.
Yeah, I could post that in the chat
or something if you want. Yes.
Say hello in the YouTube chat
and then I'll make you a moderator
and you can post links.
So I'll. Yeah.
So then.
Okay, I'll continue on that.
Yeah.
I mean regarding the actual question
about what to sort of start with,
I think that depends a lot
on what you want to do.
So there's kind of three
big topics in my mind
is that so if the step is a hardcore
math of the theory
as it's presented in particular physics,
and so that I'm not sure
there is necessarily a good beginner's
level results at this point,
like there is essentially
when our paper tries
to get to a quite straightforwardly
and then they have you have to Thomas
Blanket since the catechism is a paper
which covers the main points
but it's not like a tutorial
that states like this is x, y,
and then really it's just
the particular physics monograph is where
most of that information is like this
and yet a really nice laying out of it.
And obviously we
try and do it on our paper, but obviously
we're also focused on the actual point
you want to make. It's
not just like specifically tutorial.
Yeah.
I mean the other two things,
obviously the active
sort of discrete state based active
inference that people talk a lot about.
I think the best resource for that
at the moment
is probably Lancelot,
the cost review on that.
And then there is yeah,
just then essentially
there's some several calls papers
which I think
I talk about my GitHub apology, which is
kind of getting into more detail.
But Lance's review for
that is really good.
And then there's
a sort of more continuous state based
predictive coding style,
which I think I think Chris is out.
His 2017 review is
is the best for that to be honest.
So yeah, are
honorable.
Yeah, I think Chris is one is the one
if you want to understand the whole
the theory and all the methods
of how this works very nicely.
I was like, if you want to build
a predictive coding network which works
and you have that sort of more more
focused on the neuroscience,
I would say that the way to go.
If I can ask one now
before Michael's answer, when you said
neuroscience, do you see them
as just historically juxtaposed
or do you see some of these approaches
as encompassing one another
or being prerequisite to one another?
So I think the idea is that the sort of
in the particular physics
monograph encompasses all of them
and that that the idea is that
these are two specific models.
You know, you have a specific
have a specific vibrational density,
specific generative model.
And then you work through the mathematics
at these
these process theories is called
close them out.
I mean, I think practice to the extent
they can stand alone away from whatever
the particular physics monograph says,
because they are with you
making their empirical predictions
about the brain or whatever.
And so you can actually
totally test these.
And so even if all of particular
physics is wrong,
then these things could be like invites
of ascertained objectivity,
if you like, and these things
could just not be what the brain is doing
between something else.
They I think they stand alone,
although in theory
the particular physics monograph
is kind of meant to subsume them all.
Thanks for that response.
And Miguel to original question,
what would you recommend a beginner
to be learning and looking into.
And yeah, I'm not so sure.
For me.
So I think, yeah, you started
with the Thomas Spar paper about Marco
blankets and promising geometry
and then going back to the
to the monograph
of a particular physics on the.
But but it was,
it was challenging because yeah, it's
it wasn't complex on and yeah it was
and I kind of like it was useful
to Martin be this paper are technical
critical of the front end
yeah the free energy principle
in the sense
it was very technical and formal but
it was useful that they tried
to encapsulate
the different conditions
in a way similar to what we do here.
And I think that was helpful
to try to to differentiate different,
the different steps which are not always
so clear in the, in the literature.
So, so yeah.
I think, yeah, I think there is at least
for the part regarding the free energy
principles describing there
in, in particular physics, it's
and yeah,
we need to maybe get our tutorials on
but yeah, more materials
that are opposed to this introduction. So
thanks for these responses.
And I know in our active lab
and in many other associated efforts
that the focus on accessibility and,
communicating these ideas in a way that's
going to be helpful to people from
many backgrounds is a top priority.
So way back in the introduction,
you know, 120 times
steps ago,
you talked about new visualizations.
And it's definitely the case that paper
after paper will use some classical
figures, let's just say,
and I'm excited by visualizations.
And so I was curious,
just maybe whoever wants to go in for it,
what would the new representations
do or be communicate?
What style or what made
you just wanting to explore visually?
And how is that in feedback
with the research?
Hmm. Okay.
Yeah, I think that's interesting.
I like at some point
I kept looking through the literature
and it's paper up there, paper the same,
the same graph of what in our brain
since Rome with the logo.
I see this as a non.
Yes. So at some point it
stops being useful to write there
because they're like some but it's this
realization can give unique intuitions
to some extent, very and so on.
At some point I yeah.
I wants to know more about that.
So it was not,
it's not always a straightforward,
okay, there's an arrow about
what does it mean?
So why is this by their external or I'm
yeah so so
the difference here is that we have
where we developed them
with the idea of okay
how can we intuitively
express these very complex
assumptions and ask
how do you feel that flow?
Or This is sort of challenging
or an idea?
I don't I'm
not sure if we did a good job there, but
I think it's in that
I think any intuition about the principle
are are really hard to capture
because they are quite complex.
And I think it's interesting
to try to put in the directions
of, of having new images
that try to at least try to capture
that, that intuition of some
and what they mean or how to them.
Yeah.
Yeah. Because of them.
I think you have to do with the theory
based on your intuition
or cooperating with intuitions, that part
that you don't understand yet, especially
if you're learning this kind of thing,
I think is incredibly useful
in general in Central
pressure.
Bear And
would you like to add on that point?
No, just that we found it hard.
I mean, because it's so,
so many different types of interactions
we want to represent
typically monolithic arrows
between agent and environment
seems to dominate everything.
Right?
But when you start drilling down
into this,
we have the difference in causal
and functional.
Obviously people like Perl and I stuff,
I've done this in the philosophy, right?
And be very clear
about different types of interaction.
But I think it
and especially modeling work
is become a bit clouded and location
especially in the area of the free energy
principle.
But yeah, know
whether I we got in a really good job
but it does look complicated.
The final product is complicated
looking right but it does do justice
to these different
types of interaction. And.
Baron anything on that or no.
Yeah, go for it then.
I would just say that I agree.
Like I'm
not naturally a sort of visual person
who actually looks at the figures,
but I think just the what we gathered
was actually really good.
And it's the of thing
that if you actually look at them and try
and understand them, it will yield
a lot of dividends in terms of quickly
getting to grasp on precisely
what's being said, what's not being said,
because yeah, it's very easy
to having to sort of hazy interaction
without knowing what that really means.
It's The same again as a geneticist,
it makes me think of,
oh, you know, nodes are genes and edges
are interactions which kind of those
multiple classes and does one paper
use it one way and go to the methods.
And it's one way in this paper
and it's another one in another way,
but it's being cited.
And so it takes a lot of subtlety
to pull back to that question
about what kind of interactions
are being discussed.
And then, Chris, what you just said,
there's like
it's a high
praise the work that it does justice
because that's what we hope
the bleeding edge does
for the rest of the knife.
And the handle is represented
visually on a manifold
that doesn't deceive.
It's not drawing hard lines
where none exist.
It's not making false positive or false
negatives or false claims visually,
because the visual rhetoric is
how many people will learn
and think about these things.
And so that's it makes all the difference
whether there's a bi directional arrow
graphically or not,
because people are going to unpack it,
especially if they're not going to go
into the and level of math,
they're going to unpack it literally
and with the knowledge that that's
what the expert represented in their aim.
So I really do think it's
particularly important in this field
because there is a separate between this
technical morass that sits at the bottom
and obviously the ambition
and what it promises.
So, so many people are attracted
to this particular theory.
And then but not not everyone has got
time to go in and design for them.
So the thing is
the level of these figures
and trying to make this course
and so on that level.
So it's vital that those figures
become very clear and very pointed
in what they try to communicate.
And any kind of lack of clarity is
is going to send the whole community off
in the wrong direction, particularly
if you, you know,
the kind of person who wants to go in
and do the fiscal physics
and want to do more
the philosophy
or cognitive science of these systems.
So it's vital that we get them right
in this particular field,
particularly, I think.
Yes, it's
I think there's an xkcd cartoon,
you know, about where
the fields are arranged, but especially
when working with the theory itself,
it should be lean
and as low dimensional as possible
and not any more,
because otherwise it will be unpacked
in ways that are just going to be
completely discordant.
But if it can be represented
in sort of like a build in or like an opt
in at this level, instead of trying
to explain backwards from what
we could do in the future in the math,
we need to start with the axioms
and clarify what they are
and then unpack those.
And then it's like
just like with any other area of theory.
Did you disagree with the axioms or did
you disagree with how they were applied?
Because those are the areas
where there's sort of controlled space
for discussion.
But then something like
I don't think it would work that way
in a human computer interface.
It's neither here
nor there for the level of rigor
that you approach the
questions with today.
Yeah.
So I can ask any other questions
or we can see
if anyone else posts in the chat.
But that was actually one of my questions
was are those all the axioms?
How do we represent axioms or
how do we even know what those axioms are
without getting into like too much of a
whole, you know, incompleteness thing?
What are the axioms where they what
you put in the paper and nothing else,
those are necessary and sufficient.
Or is there some other stuff happening?
It's Our ambition
just to say before let me go on to that.
But then we have an ambition
to write a kind of more
accessible version of this paper, which
hopefully be done in the next few months.
So we want to do exactly that.
We want to draw away from the hostage
cycle physics and have this paper
underneath it
and then even be more even more clear
about the kind of overall narrative
of what we're suggesting here.
And we can answer those questions
to ask very directly, hopefully
for the specific
case of let me go answer.
Up. A new book and then continue.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
The two ideas that the yeah,
I think that the core principle is one
has been an evolving theory
and there is different versions
of teaching with a different person
and that then yes,
nothing has been being proposed on
least for me.
It was a difficult job to
to try to get to that, to somewhat
to summarize the theory in that way
or to add up
the exact connections of the steps.
Because until sometimes the
some descriptions are better, but then
yeah,
I think that's, yeah, that's important.
Yeah.
An important avenue for continuing
the research in this field is try to
do more accessible descriptions
or more or try to encapsulate them in
and in this way
or try to get just to show this sequence
more clearly, at least
for an introductory conference, right?
Yeah.
It's been it's been very much a very
living, very different from this one.
I wrote that review back in the day,
which is that there is this development.
It's very clear in the in the series
of publications that comes out.
And I think things things have changed,
obviously, as they as they as develop.
So trying to see the consistency
across those types of things,
which is the fundamental axiom
which is later introduced and so on,
is very difficult actually.
Again, I don't think it's a I don't
I don't criticize the authors of this
because I think it is a living theory.
It's something that's
kind of really evolved in
the literature is a very complex one.
So it had to be,
but yet hopefully
as we go forward in the next few years,
we can become more clear about
these things
and we'll be more and more people doing
reviews and more critical evaluations
like the Goldstone
will further ground this theory
in in the place where we can all agree
on and agree on the axioms.
And then I'll say.
And I just to say.
Baron and then Miguel.
Okay, guys, I want to say that, yeah,
we should definitely not consider
all the axioms and but the principle
at the moment to be completely terrific.
Then like I feel this is still living
and still evolving in many ways
and there's some case to have questions
about do we actually need this axiom
kind of be more general in this kind of
be less general than this and stuff.
So I think there's going to be
lots of more foundational discussion
around the actual axioms underlying it.
And now the people are
just really just starting to tackle
and in particular physics
and really deep way
that I think that that
will over the next few days
be lots of discussion about this.
And hopefully in a couple of years
we'll have a much more precise statement
of what the FIP says,
what is needed, what isn't needed,
and how everything fits together.
But at the moment
is still in a bit of flux, like because
really deep critique outside of Karl's
grip on particular physics is kind of
just really starting
in the last year or so.
Thanks for that, Miguel.
Yeah, yes. So it's on to other.
Okay.
So so we focus on the free energy
principle and on this claim that
these dynamic systems
or operating systems behave as minimizing
the free energy, but they think that's
only one part of the universe.
The reality is you have the active
in front, you have the design of systems
that explicitly minimize the free energy
and thus are completely forbidden.
And often this is also mix and not so.
And yeah,
and there's some things are mixed between
so which is the the axioms
in the beginning the specific repair.
So what, what are you,
what are you actually doing.
The in your work is not always clear for
for anyone because these have all been
that is separation of the theory
and this interconnections and so on.
But I think that
yeah like are becoming more mature
as their field becomes more mature.
This should be clearer because
sometimes this leads to confusion
about what the theory means.
It's not when people say, okay,
the free trade
principle shows that every living system
is minimizing.
Okay, but, and it's yeah.
So, so it's different
when you think of aliens that do it by,
by design or when you try to the claim
to other system non.
So there is this different points of view
on the different sides of the theory
that, that, yeah, I, I,
I hope that the a mind
that we are going to evolve into a more
or an open
compartmentalized and
they are interconnected,
but the way that they are clear
and the borders of the
different planes and so on.
It's going to be in.
FP Metaverse.
That is appropriate
for the online age, honestly,
because when I think about how the needle
was pushed here, GitHub,
an interactive computational preprints
like yours,
live streams like the one
that we're on a discord server, you know,
a reading group that was arranged
by Maxwell and others ten years ago.
20 years ago,
it would have been like, what?
And it certainly wouldn't
have been accessible globally.
So to see how the material
and the informational culture
and also social culture is changing
in a time when participatory science
and open science
and all these kinds of transdisciplinary
ideas are coming to the fore,
it's just an awesome contribution.
So I'll offer any final thoughts
from a chat and each of you a final
word.
But just to say from the lab that we
really appreciate your willingness
to, you know, jump on at short notice
and work on it and share it in this way,
and also with these exciting directions
that you've planned out
and expect.
I'm out,
but I say I completely agree with you
and I have to, you know,
shout out to people like Maxwell Rand
study organizes this course service,
which are now really
this debate in Y communities.
And you're really valuable for
an infrastructure for people like this
to come in and do this type of research.
So yeah, I completely agree with that.
This this new infrastructure is
really important to this type of stuff.
Erin, any last comments
and then Miguel, of course.
Yeah, final word.
And I just want to echo what Chris said
really about just the sheer importance
of the reading actually organized this.
I think that's why, you know,
I learned an awful lot
about how particular physics works
and how everything goes through
in that monograph.
And I think a lot of people did
that as well.
Like,
I think that we didn't really build up
enough expertize to make papers like this
and obviously similar to modern stuff
and to get anything together, probably
lots of stuff in the next year or so.
Coming out
actually made all of that possible.
And so, yeah, all of that.
This is a family like if you're
interested in learning more about the FP
like email Maxwell
because he has recordings
of all of the reading group meetings.
And so that's probably going to be
a really cool thing.
For a good into the lockdown
I think know.
History
I can recall lots of material there
if you want to really drill down
into the technicalities
and those recordings
will probably be really good as well.
Great and
now if
you would like to give any last comments
and. Yeah, yes.
Well, yes, yes.
As you said,
I think we're on partly as Chris
Burns said, I,
I can often relate to the group.
And yes, I think the two last sessions
by the it was really helpful to to dig
through the some of the discussions
that took place there.
And I think in general
what's so I think in general, yeah.
What's cool feel advances too
to make things accessible
in different ways and
and this can be through resources
through communities and also through more
transparent models or more
and easier
to follow guides through the maps.
And I think that is part of the
difficulties in the field is that there
is this disconnection between people
that is doing mathematical work
and people like this
doing philosophical work.
And not only here, what I think
in cognitive science in general or
or even the more and deeper
use of systems, biology
and so on, right on
and that this new level
now I think is very valuable.
This is efforts in in in trying
to make things more accessible and easier
to follow from, you know, for people
from multiple disciplines.
I think that's a very valuable effort
that we should try to do
collectively because that's the only way.
And thanks a lot
for hosting this session.
Thank you.
We always talk about tools, ideas
and people.
They're a triple helix.
And so thanks for making it happen
with all of those today.
Thank you very much for that. Peace!